The patients are the trials.
His experimenting on people.
I thought. This.
Oh, his claims of the trachea regenerating
blood supply epithelium in animals, blah
blah blah. It was all made up.
Jesus Christ.
Christopher Lyles.
I'm sorry. I can't imagine what he went
through. I can.
Your rats. They all had different causes of
death. Suffocation, heart attack, shock.
But they had one thing in common.
They all suffered.
Chris Lyle suffered.
We have to show this to Handley all of this.
Yeah, I agree.
We must inform Handley.
But we cannot use the force data.
What are you talking about? We need as much
damaging information as possible.
I crossed serious lines by going to her.
Breached patient confidentiality, I could get
fired. Or worse.
We need this.
No, we don't.
My trials are enough.
Shut up! I didn't say anything.
Pain and persistent cough are coming from
somewhere.
It could be unseen damage to the membrane
around her tracheal cartilage.
Macaroni, I see it. What is she on?
Standard cocktail.
If she's stable, she's got no allergies
listed.
It's not the medication.
Check the vent quickly.
It's not the vent.
Then it must be an early in her trachea.
But it just.
There's some bleeding in her right lung.
I need to open up her chest.
But we're not prepared.
Just do it.
Thoracotomy, O.R.
three
three.
Blood's cooling in the right lung.
Blood pressure.
O2 is dropping.
Oh, my God there's infected tissue.
We can't suture.
What do we do?
My report supports our concerns, Dr.
Handley.
Well, it says here these rats died of various
complications from heart failure, stroke,
infection. And the one
thing in common, the
trachea. The results are not definitive, but
we would argue they may be enough to justify
running additional trials before continued
use on our patients.
These are experimental treatments, and
they're used to care for patients with no
other options.
I see a great deal of evidence of positive
results, certainly nothing that could be
outweighed by one rat trial that you
yourself defined as inconclusive.
Do you have any further data?
No, Doctor Handley. Not at this time.
Isn't this enough?
Guy's a hack. I've had a bad feeling about
him since he stepped- Doctor Handley.
We're urging you to review the data.
Come to your own conclusion.
Sorry.
Handley. Right.
Yep, yep. Okay.
Thank you. Uh, gentlemen, we will review
your concerns internally.